for more than a week these messages have
been posted online
one after the other hermanos
brothers and sisters if you are watching
this video it is because i have been
detained by ortega's regime you're
seeing this video it means my house is
being raided and i've been kidnapped
if you are seeing this video it means
i've been captured
if you are seeing this it means i've
been detained by the police
these are only some of the recently
imprisoned opponents of nicaragua's
ruling couple
president daniel ortega and his wife
rosario murillo
his vice president five of them
are aspiring presidential challengers
for november's elections
others are opposition party leaders
journalists even bankers and prominent
members of the business sector
the majority of them are accused of
violating national sovereignty and
independence
in her latest recorded message to
nicaraguans mrs ortega called them quote
servants to a foreign god
they are rubbish who else would attempt
to submit their people to the wishes of
those who have committed the worst
crimes the world's over
the same ones who dropped atomic bombs
on the japanese
she's referring to the united states
ortega's former enemy during the left to
sandinista revolution the top of
nicaragua samosa dictatorship in 1979.
now a great many of daniel ortega's
former comrades in
arms accuse him of replacing the samosa
dynasty
with his own family
legendary guerrilla commander dora maria
and general hugo torres who rescued
ortega from prison during the sandinista
insurrection
have also just been arrested
46 years ago i risked my life to get
daniel ortega out of jail
i am 73 years old i never thought that
at this stage of my life
i would be fighting in a peaceful civic
way against a new dictatorship
one of the few critics still free is
opposition alliance leader lester aleman
who led a student revolt three years ago
he says ortega's strategy is to
discourage nicaraguans from going to the
polls
at all in november
the idea is to generate total discredit
so that there is massive abstention that
way daniel ortega can say
i want fair and square i just didn't
have any competition
human rights watch is asking the un
secretary general to invoke article 99
of the charter to bring the matter
before the security council
calling it a threat to regional security
the fact that nicaragua can do this with
impunity without
any meaning for the repercussions
internationally
could send a very wrong message to other
central american governments
that are going towards undemocratic
practices
president daniel ortega who has not been
seen in public for more than a month
has not responded to requests for
comment
lucia newman al jazeera